trey gowdy you can kind of impress me a
little bit here a guy that used to be a
prosecutor I watched you you've had a
lot of good moments when when you drill
down into somebody it usually gets
pretty hot for that person because you
base things on facts I want to ask you
what are the main questions you think
are unanswered by Robert Muller
I watched you in Benghazi I've watching
some other moments you're a prosecutor
that's never lost the case what would
you ask him what needs to be answered
well Sean first of all thank you very
much for having me on I want you to
think in terms of buckets and I frankly
would start keep in mind Devon and Jimmy
and Ratcliffe only have five minutes so
you have to be very strategic and have a
pretty narrow goal start with bias you
got read of Peter Peter struck because
he wanted Clinton to win and Trump to
lose but yet you hired people who wanted
Clinton to win and Trump to lose so how
much bias are you willing to put up with
you fired struck but you hired a bunch
of prosecutors who felt the same way
number two
someone needs to ask about this legal
issue if you can resist an unlawful
arrest can you resist an unprejudiced
mauler to go to the origins of this
Russia investigation and how much time
did he spend cycling through that then I
would go to what did you find no
collusion no criminal collusion despite
two years what did you not find an
indictable offense for obstruction of
justice and then this is a category and
I would encourage Devon and Jimmy to
think about this what did you not bother
to look for yo just got through talking
about Samantha power and other people in
the American government that may have
wanted to influence either an election
or the administration we spent two years
focused on whether a foreign country was
going to influence or interfere with our
election Mahler did you look at our own
government did you look at what our own
people were doing to maybe put their
finger on the scale did you interview
Christopher steel do you know which
Russians were feeding dirt to the
American electorate via the DNC did you
interview Glynn Simpson did you
interview Jim Comey about why he leaked
those memos so there are five categories
there's biased the legal issue
what did you find what did you not find
and then importantly what did you not
even bother to look for